Yeah, this little dog. We should just jump. I got it. Just give me a sec. Yeah.
Yeah.
What's poppin. I've never seen him do it all at this moment.
He realized he was being sarcastic. Oh yeah, I got it. All right. Yeah. Yeah.
Not shaking, shaking, shaking. Yo. What's up man. Stop it.
I'm trying to plug my merch. Yo, what's up fashion.
Okay. Let's do it again. I was so guys, let me show you. If you like fashion,
you're going to love this boom and get in trouble. So I
carry on my peasants. Don't don't make me drop.
Thank you. Thank you.
Wait didn't you do your intro like five times. Oh,
but this is real intro. Now I'll put that makeup.
You have orange stuff on your mouth. I do like the sauce. Yeah.
I do piggy right here. That one. Yeah.
I don't need dental.
All right. So we are driving to Tomlin now. And then, you know,
we're still at work technically, you know,
because it is a Thursday and it's like 1245.
So that's why I'm still working.
So see here I have a laptop and I'm working out.
I can't fill my at work because I need a, in my hands from the camera.
But can you call me real quick, please keep filming
one second. Okay. Okay. I got this
shirt
for a big one
to split it up. Well, that's the thing I say. You want a big one?
Let's do some block section. Yeah. Block section. What?
Good. Can you, can I shoot him? Your, my camera
idea. Who's that collaborative?
No, she's just here. I'm just eating. She's motto.
[Inaudible] dude. I.
Did. I brought joggers. I brought my ultra boosts.
Let's go. Sorry. I also slipped her. Right.
You can leave some stuff out if you need help.
Wow. Thanks for nothing. I'm.
Going to do it. I'm doing my hands are full Lexi.
Holy.
Love seeing houses.
That one has a little door. So funny. I want to go upstairs.
Turn on
the fireplace.
[inaudible] what the is the point of that?
Oh. That's so cool. That's like what? You would want, like
everyone to pay attention to me. Oh.
These beds are legit.
Okay. This one has a bath.
Oh. So warm. You'll be delete. Delete the heater on. Oh,
connected bathroom.
Okay.
You, I want the one, this one. This one is. I want that one.
No that. You guys aren't going to use the door.
Yeah, this is so dope. You should just jump. Yeah, dude. I got it.
Just give me a sec. Yeah.
Oh, you should do like running through.
This is the best room. Those are my favorite.
Favorite.
[inaudible] I think they pull out which that's for boring. Yeah.
Ready to go. As far as I got
wait, God got it. My face.
I should intense blogging out. I've never even gotten like
career fairs. No way they give you that. Hey,
let's do a little bit of a thank you or call for.
Thank you for sponsoring me. Please sponsor me.
Send me more selfie sticks. I don't even know what Oracle does. Are you serious?
It's a database. It's a database. Probably databases. Yeah.
Um.
Sweet. Sweet. Oh, you know,
I used to work at McDonald's or you start working at McDonald's and they taught
me how to do the S shape like this for popping. Yeah. I don't think, uh,
I don't think you guys know how to do this. I've been trained for a year.
Okay.
Can you throw at me and pretend I, Oh man.
Oh, no, we're having so much fun. I had to stop it. Oh, stop it.
[inaudible].